bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre une table ronde organisée
par la mission commune d'information du
sénat sur la politique en faveur des
jeunes fait une mission présidée par la
sénatrice raymonde le texier
cette table ronde se présente sous la
forme d'un échange avec les syndicats
étudiants sur les thèmes de la formation
de l'orientation de l'emploi mais
également de l'autonomie des 16 25 ans
cette table ronde intervient dans un
contexte social particulièrement
difficile pour les jeunes
le nombre de chômeurs de moins de 25 ans
pourrait en effet grimpé jusqu'à 650
mille en 2009 du jamais vu depuis 1994
nicolas sarkozy a d'ailleurs annoncé un
plan d'urgence en faveur des jeunes
basé sur l'essor de l'apprentissage et
sur la formation en alternance tout de
suite donc direction la salle clemenceau
pour cette table ronde avec les
syndicats étudiants je vous salue
messieurs j'aimerais dire mesdemoiselles
mais tant fait pour vous
en mon nom et au nom de des membres de
de cette mission que nous avons donc
c'est vraiment de texier la présidente
de de cette mission monsieur de mu et on
est à porter cette mission a vu le jour
il ya juste une semaine on a commencé
nos auditions hier les sénateurs ont
souhaité mettre en place cette mission
d'information sur la politique en faveur
des jeunes compte tenu des difficultés
multiples et que nous percevons est
relative à la jeunesse on a choisi la
tranche de travailler sur la tranche
d'âge 16 25 ans sachant que ce n'est pas
exhaustif et que ne sont pas non plus
exhaustif les thèmes que nous avons
retenue et qui nous paraissent les plus
urgents vraiment urgent à traiter
à savoir tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'emploi donc et sur lesquelles on va
vous demander vos points de vue c'est à
dire c'est à dire orientation formation
emploi
on voudrait travailler et on vous
proposera peut-être de le mettre dans le
même paquet dans la même première
intervention sur ce qui est autonomie
des jeunes c'est-à-dire revenus des
jeunes ou absence de revenus des jeunes
une deuxième un deuxième tour de table
on regroupera si vous le voulez bien
les problèmes de logement des jeunes qui
nous paraissent également très important
et on pourrait également parler des
problèmes de santé
les thèmes que nous abordons sont plus
limités que nous le souhaitions est bien
évident que si vous avez des
informations à nous donner
vous pouvez nous les faire parvenir par
note par dossier ça aurait chira bien
entendu notre réflexion
on vous passe la parole je ne sais pas
comment vous voulez intervenir
on va commencer par le doublé de
monsieur c'est pas une mauvaise idée
c'est pas une mauvaise idée alors
allez-y si je peux me permettre
bonjour à tous merci à vous présenter
mon fils jean-baptiste prévost je suis
président de l'unef merci déjà de de
votre invitation et cette table ronde
bon je lui à séparation vous avez fait
en entre les différents thèmes madame la
présidente est un peu artificiel mais je
vais m'y contraindre
de manière volontaire le constat que
nous faisons aujourd'hui à l'unef sur la
situation de la jeunesse avant de
revenir à à quelques propositions sur
les thèmes que vous évoquez
c'est le constat suivant la jeunesse est
une transition
dans la vie d'un individu et la jeunesse
devrait être l'âge de tous les possibles
ou les individus peuvent construire leur
projet de vie d'insertion de formation
en étant libre d'un certain nombre de
contraintes
or ce que l'on constate c'est que malgré
l'allongement de la durée des études
malgré l'évolution d'ailleurs de la
société des besoins en termes de
qualification qui lie à imposer malgré
également une un âge de plus en plus
longs entre la sortie de la scolarité
obligatoire et l'entrée dans le premier
emploi stable depuis une trentaine
d'années la société n'a pas mis en place
en direction de la jeunesse
les mécanismes de protection et les
réponses politiques à même de couvrir ce
nouvel âge de la vie de la même manière
que après la seconde guerre mondiale
alors même que après le travail un
nouveau temps de la vie étaient apparues
notamment l'âge de la retraite que la
société avait mis en place un système de
retraite solidaire pour sortir les uns
vis des individus de la solidarité
familiale ou du travail pauvre bien sûr
pardonnez moi vous n'êtes pas du tout en
cause c'est moi qui suis en cause je
vais me faire gronder
parce que j'ai oublié de vous dire que
vous disposiez chacun de maximum 10
minutes d'accord pour chacun des thèmes
par ailleurs sont injustes qui trust
de mu est le rapporteur propose d'entrée
de jeu avant vous interveniez de vous
dire sur quoi ils allaient précisément
vous questionnez après votre
intervention
si tu peux vous permettre peut-être de
sérier un peu vos propos peut-être l'anc
dix minutes et les questions mais c'est
moi qui suis en cause pas du tout
d'accord pas du tout
alors on vous demande pas de répondre
tout de suite aux questions de l'accord
que deux mecs mais ça vous permet de
douala 2 situé de situer pts de série un
peu vos propos donc je laisse monsieur
des murs et que vous restez les
questions je suis désolé je suis une
présidente complètement nue enfin je
crois en l'occurrence bien plus de
questions la première question ça
concerne la manière de renforcer
l'efficacité des dispositifs
d'orientation d' améliorer
l'articulation entre lycées et
universités
selon vous est-ce que le dispositif
d'orientation active commence à porter
ses fruits
troisième question la loi relative aux
libertés et responsabilités des
universités a confié une mission
d'insertion professionnelle les
universités organise-t-elle efficacement
ses structures
comment répondre au double problème
récurrent qui est le suivant de nombreux
jeunes diplômés ne trouvent pas d'emploi
tandis que nombreux employeurs surtout
dans certains secteurs ne trouve pas de
personnes qualifiées pour occuper les
emplois qu'il prend pour une autre
question comment à votre avis régler le
problème de la première année de faculté
est ce qu'il faut modifier mettre en
place des passerelles puisque
aujourd'hui vous êtes obligés d'aller
jusqu'à la fin de l'année est ce que
c'est une un problème sur lequel vous
avez des idées des suggestions à faire
voilà les quatre questions que je
souhaiterais vous posez sur cette
première partie
d'autres questions auxquelles nous
répondons tout de suite forcément
d'accord ok minutes sont là et c'est une
orientation on est contraint par
l'autoroute aller à l'essentiel c'est à
dire aux propositions j'entends mais
nous mêmes même si defacto glace moi je
gouvernemental sur la jeunesse et la
mission de martin hirsch se veut
volontairement globale et c'est je crois
une bonne approche et je souhaiterais
quand même qu'on puisse avoir un débat
politique sur le sujet en tout cas c'est
notre approche donc je vais aller vite
sur le constat je vais vite venir aux
propositions et aux réponses à vos
questions
donc premier constat nouvel âge de la
vie non couvert par aucun statut social
deuxième constat je voudrais revenir sur
quatre fautes politiques ou 4 mauvaise
approche que par le passé on a eu en
direction de la jeunesse et qui dont je
crois nous devons sortir aujourd'hui
la première erreur politique qui a été
fait c'est de considérer la jeunesse
comme un mal nécessaire un purgatoire
une période dont il faudrait sortir
assez vite c'est toujours un état
d'esprit qu'on rentre rencontre et qu'on
constate notamment dans les entreprises
qui continuent à demander même à des
jeunes très qualifiés de faire leurs
preuves et de faire preuve d'une de
leurs expériences et ça c'est je crois
un premier problème
deuxième erreur une opposition qui a été
fait par le passé entre eux deux
jeunesse jeunesse très qualifiés
sous-entendu jeunesse dorée et jeunesse
déshéritée
celle qui est non qualifiés qui sortent
du système éducatif notamment sans
diplôme je crois que ça correspond à une
réalité sociale
il ya effectivement des inégalités
fortes entre les jeunes mais et que les
situations sont différentes mais qu'il a
besoin aujourd'hui de reposer le
problème de la jeunesse dans sa
globalité et de répondre à des
aspirations qui sont communes à
l'ensemble des jeunes l'aspiration à se
former l'aspiration à l'insertion
professionnelle et le besoin d'autonomie
et je crois que à force de
viser les jeunes entre eux on a eu des
réponses partielles on a revu à la
baisse les objectifs notamment et je
crois que c'est un moyen d'en rabattre
sur les ambitions qui eux dont on doit
se passer puis ça correspond surtout à
absolument pas la réalité ou deux tiers
des jeunes aujourd'hui sont dans le post
bac se qualifie de plus en plus il ya
une règle massification et beaucoup
d'enfants des milieux populaires sont
aujourd'hui en formation supérieure
troisième erreur qui a été fait je crois
c'est que les politiques en direction de
la jeunesse ont jusqu'à présent toujours
procéder par soustraction par
soustraction par rapport à des
dispositifs et à des droits communs
notamment sur le marché de l'emploi les
marchés du travail est l'exemple type
est temps l'idée d'un smic jeunes ou
d'un contrat spécifique
il faut absolument considérer le fait
qu' un jeune à un projet de formation un
besoin de formation et aspire à une
insertion durable et qui soit la plus
stable possible et aspirent à accéder au
dispositif e de droit commun et on a
constaté que depuis une quinzaine
d'années tous les dispositifs mis en
place en direction de la jeunesse
soit ils ont été ils ont revu à la
baisse à nombre de droits soit une
reconnaissent pas la nécessaire
autonomie des jeunes par rapport à leurs
familles c'est notamment le volet
politique familiale soit les jeunes sont
entrés par effraction dans un certain
nombre de dispositifs
je pense par exemple aux aides au
logement qui aujourd'hui sont un
dispositif très efficace qui est des
jeunes à accéder à un logement
indépendant mais qui n'était au départ
pas prévu pour eux pas prévu pour eux
donc on n'est pas aujourd'hui dans une
demande avant de venir aux propositions
concrètes je termine sur mon constat
excusez moi on n'est pas dans une
demande aujourd'hui de charité on n'est
pas dans une demande aujourd'hui
d'empilement de mesures sans cohérence
pour colmater les brèches d'un système
on est dans une demande de refonte
globale est de reposer en direction de
la jeunesse
un nouveau projet politique qui réponde
à leurs aspirations qui ouvre des droits
nouveaux et qui répondent à leurs
besoins de formation et d'insertion
on parlera de la question financière
mais ça ne s'y réduit pas je crois qu'il
faut et c'est mon dernier mot sur le
constat reconnaître au préalable aussi
des situations de dépendance que
subissent les jeunes aujourd'hui
dépendance familiale qui reproduit
visibilité sociale dépendance aussi
à l'égard de situations de précarité
notamment de la précarité des petits
boulots pour ce qui concerne les
étudiants concurrents aux études et qui
augmente de près de 40% les chèques
notamment en premier cycle universitaire
donc il faut poser au préalable des
objectifs pour nous l'objectif ça doit
bien être de donner les moyens à une
génération de construire son projet de
vie de formation et d'insertion
d'accéder à une formation supérieure
c'est le préalable pour entrer dans une
bonne condition dans la vie active et un
tel projet d'ailleurs aurait des effets
macro économiques non négligeables mais
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
pour répondre spécifiquement aux
questions que vous posiez tout d'abord
sur l'orientation l'orientation
aujourd'hui doit être considérée comme
un moyen d'aider les jeunes à construire
leur projet a comme une contrainte ou un
moyen de les décourager
c'est notamment le problème de
l'orientation active tels que nous
constatons aujourd'hui principalement
par manque de moyens l'orientation
active ne fait pas l'objet par exemple
de rendez vous individuels avec eux et
lycéens ni par les universités ni par
aucune autre structure
ça se limite souvent une réponse
automatique parfois par voie
électronique aux besoins de vos
questions que peuvent se poser les
jeunes et leurs familles est souvent
comme un moyen de réguler les flux en
fonction soit des objectifs des
établissements en terme de remplissage
de certaines filières soit en fonction
d'objectifs en termes de d'insertion
professionnelle sur lesquels on manque
de dispositifs et d'outils aujourd'hui
pour mesurer notamment les besoins en la
matière donc il y as besoin en matière
d'orientation premiers éléments de
moyens humains et de suivi individualisé
des la troisième à partir de la
troisième au lycée et dans les premiers
cycles universitaires nous sommes
favorables à l'unef à l'instauration
d'un rendez vous obligatoire
d'orientation et un est mise en place
d'un suivi d'orientation qui soit qui
suivent le lycéen et de l'étudiant
pendant tout son parcours sur
l'articulation entre lycées universités
la transition secondaire supérieur et
déterminante notamment pour mieux lutter
contre l'échec dans les premières années
à l'université
ce qu'on constate c'est que c'est
souvent un bizutage pédagogique
le premier cycle universitaire ils sont
ils sont pas préparés
deuxième constat il ya des voies de
contournement aujourd'hui qui existent
et qui font que trop souvent les
premiers cycles universitaires sont des
choix par défaut pour des lycéens qui
n'ont pas pu notamment aller dans les
filières pour lesquelles il se destinait
je pense en particulier au bac pro bac
techno
concentre aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de difficultés lorsqu'ils sont les
universités et pour lesquelles on avait
mis en place des filières qui ont été
dépouillés leur objectif initial je
pense au bts et aux iut notamment je ne
développe pas mais il faut poser la
question des structures c'est un élément
important notamment dans l'enseignement
supérieur et unifier notre système en
tout cas rééquilibrer notre système
d'enseignement supérieur au bénéfice des
universités
deuxième remarque il y as besoin de
changer la pédagogie en premier cycle
universitaire on est encore trop dans le
modèle des cours en amphithéâtre à
l'ancienne et d'une pédagogie qui par
manque de moyens et plus individualisé
et effet qu en sorte que les étudiants
sont perdus dans les premiers cycles il
faut détecter les chèques et les
situations d'échec dans les premières
années il faut notamment l'orientation
active pourrait servir à cela mais ne le
fait pas aujourd'hui pour mettre en
place au cours du premier semestre des
dispositifs de rattrapage et de lutte
contre l'échec
troisième remarque il faut mieux
préparer les lycéens à l'enseignement
supérieur dans le cadre d'une réforme du
lycée qui notamment prépare à
l'autonomie des lycéens dans le travail
et qui leur donne un sombre de prérequis
méthodologie qui leur manquent dans les
premiers cycles je pense à la recherche
documentaire au travail en groupe à la
nécessité de construire un travail qui
soit - travail scolaire et bien
évidemment quatrième élément dans les
premiers cycles universitaires il ya un
besoin de renforcer l'encadrement qui
aujourd'hui sous les moyennes
européennes en la matière y'a pas assez
d'encadrement humains dans les premiers
cycles c'est vrai pour tous les sujets
l'orientation dans les premières années
les bibliothèques peu ouverte mais aussi
sur l'encadrement en termes
d'enseignement tant qu'on n'aura pas
réglé cette question là et qu'on mettra
pas au niveau les universités par
rapport aux classes prépas aux grandes
écoles vous même venir cette européenne
matière d'encadrement premier cycle la
lutte contre l'échec restera une vaine
promesse et donc j'ai répondu sur
l'échec en premier cycle en partie est
mon dernier mot sera sur la mission
d'insertion des professionnels des
universités notre sentiment c'est qu'on
a un peu réinventer la poudre en 2007
sur ce sujet ça faisait bien longtemps
que les universités s'étaient posé la
question du lien au monde du travail
avait créé des iut ont pareil
d'établissement public à caractère
scientifique culturel et professionnel
depuis 1984 donc il ya eu beaucoup
d'habillage
autour de cet élément là si on regarde
dans le détail les universités ont un
rôle pour mieux préparer les étudiants à
l'insertion professionnelle
c'est la question des stages encadrés et
rémunéré intégrés dans les cursus est le
corollaire doit être d'ailleurs leur
interdiction
après le diplôme notamment on y
reviendra peut-être en parlant d'emploi
mais c'est aujourd'hui un moyen de ça
crée un effet d'aubaine pour les
entreprises
et ça empêche les jeunes d'accéder à une
offre une solution de l'embauché stable
deuxième élément prévoir des contenus
d'enseignement au sein des cursus de ce
point de vue là on en a très peu et vous
évoluez modules d'enseignement qui
prépare à l'insertion professionnelle
troisième élément avoir au sein des
universités des lieux des bureaux qui
permettent de concentrer l'offre de
stages de mettre en place un suivi des
stages et de mettre à disposition des
informations sur l'impression
professionnelle l'aebea ip prévus par la
loi sur l'autonomie ont été peu mises en
place également en particulier par man
que par manque de moyens
remarque générale il faut de notre point
de vue si on veut traiter sérieusement
cette question d'insertion
professionnelle sortir d'un débat public
qui aujourd'hui dont la tonalité
aujourd'hui ne permet pas d'aborder
cette question de manière satisfaisante
puisque notamment on est en permanence
dans une mise en accusation du système
éducatif quasiment responsables du
chômage des jeunes je crois qu'on n'en
sortira pas et qu'on n'arrivera pas à
trouver les bons dispositif si
l'approché uniquement uniquement celle
ci dernière remarque sur l'emploi je
suis désolé c'est un peu décousu mais je
me pris aux contraintes de l'exercice ça
sera mon dernier sujet sur la question
de l'emploi je crois qu'il faut marcher
sur ses deux jambes sur les deux jambes
en matière d'emploi des gens des jeunes
il ya la question d'aider des jeunes non
qualifiés qui ont un besoin prioritaire
d'accès à une formation qualifiante de
ce point de vue là les dispositifs
proposés par martin hirsch de
d'apprendre de contrats d'apprentissage
de professionnalisme d'alternance sont
une réponse intéressante leur montée en
puissance
à la condition qu'il y ait une
perspective d'embauché clair à la suite
et qu on résoud qu'on résolve pardon
excusez moi la question du taux de
rupture partis flamands importants
notamment dans les contrats
d'apprentissage
aujourd'hui c'est un problème et on peut
pas faire comme si c'était une solution
valable et sans aucune qui ne posent pas
aucune difficulté deuxième remarque mais
la deuxième jambe également qu'il faut
attaquer c'est qu'il faut s'attaquer
c'est celle des jeunes qualifiés ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux et qui
sont eux en discuter lors de l'entrée
dans le marché de l'emploi
nous on propose plusieurs choses la
première donc c'est évacuer toutes les
solutions qui participe d'une précarité
importantes je parlais des stages hors
cursus
je pense qu'il faut aussi résorber un
maximum les emplois précaires dans les
jeunes sont les collégiens de son
premier occupés qui nous permettent pas
une insertion durable et de qualité
je crois qu'il faut également
reconnaître mieux les qualifications
notamment dans le cadre des conventions
collectives puisque l'on se rend compte
que les entreprises bénéficient des
compétences acquises et les
connaissances des jeunes diplômés sans
les reconnaître ni les rémunérer il ya
un effet d'aubaine important qui
participent d'un peu d'une désespérance
je pense chez les jeunes qui rencontrent
des difficultés d'insertion
professionnelle et dernière remarque et
c'est une proposition que nous
formulions notamment auprès de martin
hirsch besoin de protéger et de
sécuriser d'un point de vue social et la
période de recherche du premier emploi
qui aujourd'hui pendant laquelle les
jeunes diplômés n'ont pas droit à
indemnisation chômage suffisant malgré
les dispositions prévues par l'accord
entre les partenaires sociaux en janvier
dernier et n'ont droit à aucun minima
social on chiffre les besoins en termes
de financiers internes de recherche dans
3 à 4 à 500 euros par mois c'est à peu
près le coût d'un mois de recherche
d'emploi il faut sécuriser cette période
de recherche d'emploi et l'accompagner
et mettre en place un accompagnement
individuel des jeunes aujourd'hui qui
n'existe pas ou qui est trop faible
notamment dans le cadre des missions
locales
donc je crois que sur la recherche du
premier emploi et notamment sur la liste
et de mieux sécuriser cette période il
ya un enjeu de réformes important pour
les jeunes diplômés
le prochain à prendre la parole très
bien vous vous présenter on essaie
précédent les dix minutes tout à fait
donc machine un quartier vice président
de la fage la fédération des
associations générales étudiantes donc à
la fois organisations représentatives
les organisations de jeunesse je
remplace la présidente au pied levé dans
quelque ironie un peu plus de féminité
dans ce groupe vocal je m'en excuse
alors concernant la jeunesse pour nous
la jeunesse et donc une perte de 15 à 25
ans c'est la pub fondamentales de la vie
qui va déterminer énormément l'avenir de
chacun chaque jeune sur sur le reste de
sa vie
c'est une période qui va aux termes
d'emploi en termes intellectuels en
termes culturels lui donner des acquis
et lui permettent plus ou moins d'avoir
un tremplin ou au contraire de partir
avec un handicap dans sa vie qui vont le
pénaliser qui va avoir beaucoup de mal à
continuer par la suite au niveau de la
fage on note qu'il ya une multiplicité
pour cette tranche d'âge ce dispositif
qui existe et on a un séquençage de la
jeunesse entre les étudiants d'un côté
les jeunes qui n'ont pas d'emploi qui
sont issus donc ils font de la formation
ou autre et donc tout un groupe
finalement hétérogène qui existent en
terme de jeunesse pour nous ce qu'il
fondamental c'est de recréer une
certaine homogénéité et de créer une
sorte de dispositifs ou un jeune de 15
ans entre et va pouvoir combler on va
dire les inégalités qui existent entre
entre les différentes de jeunes de cette
classe d'âge
alors il est illusoire de penser qu'on
va réussir à rééquilibrer totalement les
inégalités qui existent soit toujours
avec justement des étudiants qui seront
plus fortunés que d'autres mais il faut
au moins permettre d'obtenir un socle on
va dire un minima qui va permettre à ces
jeunes d'avoir un véritable tremplin
d'arrivée de combler les lacunes qui
peuvent exister tant en termes
financières en termes culturels ou en
termes intellectuels de telle sorte
qu'ils puissent avoir de véritable
chance pour la venue ce dispositif doit
être doit englober tout ce qui existe
actuellement
c'est à dire d'un côté au niveau des
étudiants donc ça c'était assez simple
financièrement c'est tous les systèmes
de bourses qui existe avec notamment une
gros fonds de générale du système
malgré tout il existe
le système actuel ne tient pas
véritablement compte de l'étudiant lui
même il se base sur les ressources des
parents il ya des effets de seuil qui
sont créées par les différents échelons
de bourse et on peut avoir pour 10 euros
de différence de revenu au niveau des
bourses qui est important et qui ne peut
ne pas être justifiée donc et une
refonte à avoir au niveau d'un jeune qui
n'est pas dans l'enseignement supérieur
et qui par exemple voudrait à un projet
professionnel qui ne s'inscrit pas dans
une démarche d'enseignement supérieur il
serait intéressant d'avoir un petit peu
comme ce qui peut déjà les visites et
les fades et j donc les fonds d aide
pour les jeunes dans certaines régions
une sorte de tremplin de financement qui
va permettre de construire à 2 pour ce
jeune une certaine un avenir
professionnel et un projet professionnel
est une sorte qu'ils aient un accueil et
un accompagnement tout au long de son
projet professionnel de jazz sorte
qu'ils puissent partir avec lui aussi
une insertion convenable au delà de tout
ce qui est financier j'avais un petit
peu plus tard il ya aussi en termes vous
parliez d'orientation tout ce qui était
un petit peu insertion professionnelle
il faut pas se leurrer un étudiant un
jeune de 15 ans n'a pas obligatoirement
les mêmes compétences
les mêmes chances on va dire qu'un autre
qui sera plus fortunés je vais prendre
mon exemple j'avais des difficultés en
mathématiques quand j'étais jeune j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir des parents qui
m'ont payé une remise à niveau
malheureusement si un étudiant ou un
jeune n'a pas ces possibilités là il
part avec un désavantage
il faut aussi mettre en place toute une
un dispositif de remise à niveau des
jeunes de cette tranche d'âge et aussi
au niveau de l'université actuellement
le baccalauréat déverse un petit peu on
va dire est un petit peu on arrive au
lycée l on donne le barca a énormément
d'étudiants enfin de jeunes futurs
étudiants en disant bon quelque part on
s'en débarrasse un petit peu et c'est à
l'université de trouver la solution pour
les insérer pour les pour les
recycler en quelque sorte qu'il n'arrive
pas là aussi et tout un dispositif à
repenser un lien qui doit être repensée
avec le lycée de telle sorte non plus de
se débarrasser de ces étudiants sans
trop se préoccuper de leur avenir mais
aussi de favoriser d'autres de tout ce
qui est donc jean baptiste l'a dit tout
ce qui est bts insertion par alternance
etc qui existent et qui ont une image
négative parce que justement c'est soit
pour ceux qui sont moins bons soit que
ce pour ce coup des personnes qui n'ont
pas les moyens il faut aussi revaloriser
ces formations pour permettre à ces
jeunes de kiss qui réussissent plus ou
moins leur baccalauréat de s'insérer
dans ces filières en terme en termes
financiers une autre problématique et le
rmi le rmi n'est pas disponible pour les
jeunes de moins de 25 ans là aussi on
est un des derniers pays en europe qui
considère qu'une tragique une classe
d'âge ne peut pas avoir accès à une aide
en cas de en cas de perte d'emploi aucun
de nos emplois à mon avis le fait de
d'élargir le rsa qui existe qui était
mis en place par martin hirsch à
l'ensemble de ces catégories d'âge pour
être aussi un dispositif supplémentaire
qui va permettre une bonne insertion des
jeunes de 15 à 25 ans encore une fois ce
dispositif ne doit pas être pris de
façon isolée mais doit être inséré un
dispositif global qui prennent non
seulement en compte le côté financier
comme dit mais aussi le projet
professionnel et l'accompagnement de
jeunes ou de l'étudiant au delà de ça
j'aimerais quand même aborder un petit
peu le point de vue culturel les des
jeunes de 15 à 25 ans n'ont pas non plus
les mêmes aptitudes ou les mêmes
mêmes aptitudes culturel en quelque
sorte nos payes les mêmes avantages
culturels en fonction d'eux en fonction
de catégories sociales
là aussi on y ait des dispositifs qui
existent chez les étudiants qui sont les
pass culture ce genre de choses ça
pourrait aussi aider dans ce dispositif
pourrait aussi être inclus une
accessibilité facilitée à la culture
facilité auxi à l'obtention du permis de
conduire on en parle un petit peu c'est
sont passés à côté mais pour un jeune de
15 à 25 ans de pouvoir obtenir son
permis de conduire est quand même un
avantage fondamentale et les classes les
classes moyennes ou les classes un petit
peu plus plus pauvres ont beaucoup de
difficultés à avoir avoir cet avantage
là un autre point en terme de
financement peut être l'axé en parler de
la santé vous vouliez qu'on aborde un
petit peu la santé je vous parlais
équilibre alimentaire
prenez un étudiant il va avoir la chance
d'accéder à la restauration
universitaire donc pour 2 euros 85 un
tarif social il peut avoir un repas
équilibré constamment et donc réussir à
se nourrir convenablement
malheureusement un jeune qui n'est pas
l'enseignement supérieur qui n'a pas
accès aux services du crous lui est dans
la même tranche d'âge et n'a pas accès à
ce même à ce même service dans ces
dispositifs général d'avoir soi une
sorte de ticket restaurant pour pour
jeunes ou bien même d'élargir l'accès
des régions universitaires sont des
structures qui existent qui fonctionne
déjà bien on sait qu'elles n'ont pas une
fréquentation extrême et qui est un
petit peu un défi c'est ce niveau là ça
pourrait aussi être un avantage pour
pour les jeunes de d'accéder à ces ce
genre de choses concernant le logement
comme le communiqué l'unef les aps ont
été les étudiants c'est un petit peu
rentrer dedans par hasard et ont eu
cette chance je crois que c'est quand
même un dispositif fondamental pour
cette tranche d'âge d'accéder et d'avoir
une certaine autonomie vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis du domicile familial et vous
savez qu'actuellement c'est assez
injuste finalement quand vous êtes
étudiant on prend on ne vous n'avez pas
de revenus donc théoriquement vous avez
le maximum d'appel
mais malgré ça un barème est appliquée
de 5000 euros comme si vous touchez un
minimum de 5000 euros par an qui pour
certains étudiants qui ont qu'ils n'ont
vraiment pas de moyens les pénalise par
rapport à ceux qui auraient un travail
ou bien qu'ils ont un petit à petit vers
un petit boulot à côté est qui qui ont
plus d'appels donc là aussi une certaine
inégalité qui est mise en place et ce
système d'accès au logement est quand
même hein on va dire un accélérateur
formidable surtout pour cette tranche
d'âge sont ceux qui ont le plus besoin
d'accéder au logement et qu'ils ont
vraiment plus de 2 besoin d'avoir une
indépendance vis-à-vis de leurs familles
je crois sinon des dispositifs qui sont
à repenser mais encore une fois dans la
globalité et pas uniquement penser les
appels d'un côté les bourses de l'autre
une sorte de rmi rsa pour étudiants bon
pour jeunes d'un autre côté il faut
vraiment un dispositif global repenser
ces politiques là de façon globale pour
offrir un bain pour offrir à une sorte
de paquet en quelque sorte un jeune qui
arrive à 15 ans et qu'ils puissent avoir
en termes d'orientation en terme
financier à quoi s'en tenir et d'une
sorte de remise à niveau aussi un
plafond de telle sorte qu'ils puissent
véritablement de bien démarrer dans la
vie
pour terminer je vais encore rapidement
vous parlez de la citoyenneté très
rapidement au niveau du service civique
c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur
je crois que c'est quelque chose de qui
doit pas être obligatoire pour les
étudiants mais qui pour les jeunes mais
qui est un vrai plus un vrai plus de vie
c'est
un service à repenser à essayer de
généraliser le plus possible de donner
une expérience à cette jeunesse et c'est
aussi une démarche en termes de
citoyenneté qui peut être très
intéressante et qui à mon avis tu à
promouvoir au sein de ces futurs
dispositifs
voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près fut
au tour de la question
je répondre à vos questions par la suite
merci vous avez d'autant plus fait le
tour de la question que vous avez
brasser l'ensemble des thèmes sur
lesquels je vous proposais d'intervenir
en deux temps donc comme il est resté à
peu près dans votre timing si vous
voulez reprendre la parole sur des
points vous n'auriez pas évoquée dans
ceux des détails ne riez pas évoquée
dans les points vous venez de de brosser
largement à vous pourrez le faire tout à
l'heure je vais rechercher tout à l'air
voilà cherchait donc troisième
intervenant je vous rappelle je
souhaiterais là que vous me parliez
essentiellement d'orientation et
d'insertion professionnelle d'emploi et
ensuite on refait un petit tour pour les
ressources financières le logement
éventuellement les santé la culture on
vous écoute vous présenter oui je suis
baki youssoufou président aulas nous
sommes ici nous souhaitons rester dans
leur de représentativité si vous tes
renée rennie martial délégué national de
l'uni bons acquis une meilleure
représentativité mais jeunesse et
quelques fois plus rigide que moi je
pour parler crise à novartis donc c'est
pas une question d'âge
les iv sied bien merci en tout cas
en guise d'introduction à vous d'avoir
mené cette mission parce
qu'effectivement la question des
politiques de la jeunesse sont
aujourd'hui importante centrale et son
coeur du débat et c'est intéressant de
pouvoir en débattre entre nous permettez
moi simplement avant d'aborder
directement le les thèmes de l'emploi
l'insertion l'orientation de faire une
petite introduction sur ce qui nous
semble être important sur la politique
de la jeunesse
tout d'abord on a deux écueils à ne pas
éviter des réflexes qu'on a eu dans le
passé quand rond s'adresser à la
jeunesse une politique de jeunesse
tout d'abord évitons de mener une
politique spécifique aux jeunes
généralement d'ailleurs ça a été de les
politiques dirigées vers les jeunes
plutôt des politiques en termes de
développement associatif développement
sportif et une politique essentiellement
basée sur sur le loisir et puis d'un
côté également éviter l'écueil du d'un
certain jeunisme
je m'explique avec des créations
d'institutions pensant qu'on veut en
créant des institutions ou des jeunes se
représenter je pense notamment au
conseil national de la jeunesse aux
assises nationales de la jeunesse
pensant que ça pourrait répondre à des
besoins des jeunes non seulement ça ne
répond pas aux besoins des jeunes et en
plus ça n'a pas forcément une réelle
utilité et surtout ça confirme
l'impression que l'on pourra avoir que
la jeunesse est une étape à redon la
société et que la jeunesse est coupée en
quelque sorte d'une partie de la société
qu'il faut savoir effectivement ces deux
points il n'y a pas une jeunesse
finalement mais des jeunes est où les
jeunes sont différents on peut pas
parler s'adresser à la jeunesse de la
même manière étant donné que par exemple
un jeune quelqu'un qui est doctorant qui
à 28 ans peut se sentir plus jeune que
jeune agriculteur qui a 20 ans ou qui
montre son entreprise
donc il est difficile de s'adresser à la
jeunesse comme un seul bloc et c'est
pourquoi on comprend l'intérêt politique
de
de de faire des de s'adresser à des
jeunes 16 menées politiques entre 16 et
25 ans mais c'est vrai qu'il faudrait il
faut réfléchir aller au-delà donc ça
c'est un premier point et deuxième point
les jeunes ne demandent pas être enfermé
dans un statut par exemple parce que
c'est vrai que c'est d une idée qui peut
germer dans certains esprits de créer
des statuts de la jeunesse les jeunes
finalement ce sont d'abord des jeunes
adultes et n'aspire qu'à une chose c'est
qu'on les prenne comme tel et n'aspire
qu'à qu'à leur autonomie l'autonomie
étant effectivement un thème central
aujourd'hui un petit point là-dessus
permettez nous pour nous
l'autonomie c'est d'abord un processus
n'est pas quelque chose qui se décrète
c'est pas quelque chose qui se décide et
c'est un processus dans le temps qui est
non linéaire qui n'est pas le même pour
chaque jeune quand un jeune qui a
longtemps peut ne pas avoir deux jeunes
de 20 ans peuvent ne pas avoir forcément
les mêmes priorités au même moment
certains mais la priorité c'est d'abord
le logement d'autres c'est d'abord
l'emploi de ces d'avoir une formation
donc c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
décréter au contraire pour nous il faut
lever certains obstacles répondre à
trois priorités principales qui sont
l'accès à l'emploi qui sont l'accès au
logement et l'accès à la formation
alors juste un petit point sur
l'autonomie également il faut il faut
penser à l'accompagnement que peut avoir
aussi la famille lorsqu'on parle
d'autonomie parfois on veut aussi avoir
ce réflexe de vouloir nous couper de la
famille c'est pas forcément une volonté
et la famille il a un grand rôle à jouer
il ya l'insee qui a fait et qui a mené
une étude qui prouve notamment 88 % des
jeunes de 19 à 24 ans reçoivent une aide
financière régulière de leurs familles
est ce un taux qui monte jusqu'à 97 %
chez les étudiants donc l'autonomie
c'est effectivement vis-à-vis de la
famille mais qui doit nous accompagner
et non pas nous ne doit pas y avoir de
rupture et de dans un autre sens
l'autonomie ce n'est pas assez aussi
vis-à-vis des pouvoirs publics faire
attention
nous ne devons pas être les
récipiendaires et être les dépendants
des pouvoirs publics
lorsqu'on parle de politique de la
jeunesse alors juste quelques
propositions concernant l'emploi la
formation l'orientation
premièrement nous devons multiplier les
passerelles entre les universités les
entreprises
pour nous c'est vraiment une priorité
c'est très important effectivement ça a
été instituée l'institutionnaliser avec
la mission insertion avec la loi lru
cependant on répond à votre question il
y a encore beaucoup de choses à faire
il est difficile de faire un bilan
réellement aujourd'hui
mais si certaines universités jouent le
jeu aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas de
toutes les universités en france
nous devons favoriser l'emploi étudiant
les jobs étudiants les universités ont
un rôle à jouer important là dedans nous
nous proposons par exemple que les
universités puissent embaucher des
étudiants 10 heures par semaine pour
notamment faire la surveillance en
bibliothèque ce qui permettrait en même
temps d'ouvrir les horaires de
bibliothèques universitaires plus
tardivement ou le week-end nous devons
mettre en place de véritables bureaux
d'aidé à l'insertion professionnelle
c'est quelque chose qui a été instaurée
par la loi lru
cependant les dossiers qui ont été remis
selon un petit peu différent certains
clament le manque de moyens pour nous
les béats ip ça doit être surtout une
ouverture vers le monde extérieur et ça
devait être un moyen pour les
entreprises d'aller embaucher des
contractuels d'aller signer des
partenariats avec des vrais
professionnels de l'insertion
nous devons également multiplié des
unités d'enseignement sur la
connaissance de la vie des entreprises
parce qu'effectivement si si toutes les
filières n'ont pas la même valeur entre
guillemets professionnels
professionnalisantes il est important
pour tous les étudiants d'avoir au moins
des bases minimum de connaissance de
l'avis du monde professionnel de la vie
de l'entreprise quelles sont les
fonctions de l'entreprise comme on s'y
adresse aussi rédiger un cv savoir
rédiger une lettre de motivation savoir
aller un entretien c'est quelque chose
d'important mais qui auquel 2
aux étudiants aujourd'hui même à bac + 5
n'ont pas accès enfin concernant les
passerelles universités entreprises pour
nous il est important de pouvoir
accompagner le jeune vers un premier
emploi est une solution qui qui paie
peut-être à développer ces des stages de
fin d'études
on voit notamment dans les grandes
écoles c'est quelque chose qui marche
très bien souvent le stage de fin
d'études c'est un premier boulot
finalement à la fin du site 1 journée on
est généralement embauchés par
l'entreprise c'est encore quelque chose
qui dans les universités n'est pas
vraiment ancrée pas encore dans la
culture des universités etc
c'est un point que l'on pourrait
développer pour les jeunes qui sont mois
étudiants entre guillemets parce que là
soient excédés des propositions qui
s'adressait plutôt aux étudiants ceux
qui sont arrêtés au bac voire qu'ils
n'ont pas le bac
il nous semble intéressant de pouvoir
améliorer des dispositifs existants
plutôt que de créer des nouvelles aides
regardons déjà ce qui existe et de deux
contrats qui nous semble intéressant
c'est le contrat d'apprentissage
premièrement et le contrat de
professionnalisation qui répondent à des
attentes
en plus aujourd'hui il ya un certain
consensus visiblement et on le voit
notamment la commission hirsch qui a
l'air de se dégager pour pouvoir
développer ce ce type de dispositif donc
regarder comment faire en sorte de mieux
encourager le développement notamment
des contrats de professionnalisation et
notamment fiscalement mieux encourager
les entreprises à pouvoir développer ce
type de contrat un point sur
l'orientation pour nous c'est une
priorité aujourd'hui un vrai problème
d'orientation on se rend compte
notamment pour ce qui des les collégiens
qui vont pas forcément dans les bonnes
filières au lycée des lycéens qui vont
pas forcément dans les bonnes filières
au dans l'enseignement supérieur pour
nous l'orientation c'est un
accompagnement au quotidien qui commence
très très tôt qui cause dès le collège
qui se poursuit au lycée qui se poursuit
à l'université on a un vrai besoin
d'informations c'est pourquoi les
annonces récentes de xavier darcos avec
la création d'une classe
notre langue d'un site internet sont son
sont intéressantes où on pourrait avoir
toutes les informations et notamment sur
la réalité du marché du travail et sur
les débouchés des filières
alors d'un côté les débouchés des
filières d'enseignement supérieur des
filières des universités et puis aussi
de l'autre côté sur la réalité du marché
du travail dans tous les métiers
existants dans toutes les filières
existantes parce qu'on a un vrai besoin
d'information aujourd'hui les jeunes
sont un peu perdus parce
qu'effectivement il ya profusion
profusion de formation sauf que on leur
dit peu souvent la vérité on a besoin
d'une certaine vérité savoir que lorsque
ça on s'engage dans certaines filières
il n'y a pas forcément déboucher à la
fin et ça c'est vraiment important
d'améliorer ce dispositif d'améliorer
d'un côté donc cette information
et puisque l'on demandé ça ça touche
surtout les universités et ça a trait
aussi renie pas la loi lru ce que ce que
l'on demande c'est qui enfin les taux de
débouchés de chaque filière diplôme par
diplôme d'université universités qui
soit publiée et que ça soit pas des taux
qui qui diffère d'une inertie stand
merci tu aimé que ce soit des taux qui
sont comparables au niveau national ça
ça fait très longtemps que ça doit être
fait est là très clairement les
universités jouent pas le jeu et c'est
quelque chose d'important
enfin dernier point qui est un petit peu
différent mais il ya un lien tout de
même nous souhaitons favoriser
l'entrepreneuriat lorsque l'on voit le
succès du statut d'auto entrepreneur on
se rend compte qu'il ya une volonté
aussi d'aller vers la création
d'entreprise
et ça c'est quelque chose qui peut
s'adresser notamment à des jeunes qui
n'ont pas de diplôme ça peut être une
solution intéressante mais les jeunes
ont besoin d'outils ont besoin qu'on les
favorisent qu'on favorise un petit peu
leur initiative parce que généralement
quand on se tourne vers les jeunes il y
a on a souvent un petit peu la larme à
l'oeil sauf que les jeunes ce qu'ils
attendent des pouvoirs publics c'est
certes en partie
de pouvoir bénéficier des aides directes
mais c'est aussi surtout qu'on puisse
les aider à favoriser les aider et les
favorisés à amener leur projet
professionnel parce que on est aussi une
génération qui avons énormément de
projets qui avons énormément d'idées on
n'a qu'une envie c'est pouvoir pouvoir
concrétiser ses projets merci à vous
monsieur bonjour mathieu bac délégué
général de pdo promotion et défense des
étudiants alors ce sera tout d'abord
faire de remarques en préambule et puis
celle de répondre pragmatiquement aux
différentes interrogations quant aux
différentes pistes que vous avez soulevé
alors tout d'abord première remarque les
étudiants sont multiples divers et
variés leur origine sociale certes mais
également leur appétence pour leurs
études leur projet professionnel l'envi
de construire leur avenir est certes
présent chacun d'entre nous mais chacun
sa vision de son avenir
c'est une remarque qui pense est
nécessaire afférents en premier et la
deuxième chose c'est que nous avons vécu
depuis 40 ans une massification une
démocratisation de notre enseignement
supérieur
c'est une réelle chance pour notre pays
pour notre société pour notre pour
l'économie mais également pour faire
grandir ensemble de notre nation et donc
il fait une bonne chose qu'il ne faut
pas oublier non plus alors vous avez ce
premier thème ainsi orientation
formation insertion regrouper pour nous
c'est déjà une bonne idée de regrouper
c3 c3 tué trois thèmes puisqu'il n'ya
pas de bonne insertion sans une bonne
formation il n'y a pas une bonne
formation sont d'une bonne orientation
donc il est impossible de séparer ces
trois aspects concernant l'orientation
l'orientation se construit à ceux
construits au lycée tout au long du
lycée pour nous il est nécessaire de
renforcer les relations entre
l'université et le lycée en faisant que
pendant les heures de vie de classe qui
sont dédiés au lycée les enseignants des
professionnels viennent expliquer ce que
c'est vraiment les différents métiers
nombreux sont les étudiants qui ont 6
c'est une vision certaines icônes d'un
métier alors que c'est pas du tout celle
qui est là ce n'est pas du tout la
réelle la réalité donc les pour nous
nécessaire que l'université que
l'enseignement supérieur aille dans les
lycées rencontré les lycéens leur futur
public que les professionnels également
les rencontres et tout ça à l'intérieur
de deux heures de vie de classe qui se
fondent et qui existe déjà dans les
cursus des lycéens à travers expliquer
la différence la diversité des métiers
mais également levé cette autocensure
qui empêchent des étudiants de se
diriger vers des formations qui qui
craignent de ne pas réussir alors qu'ils
ont tout à fait les moyens un des
filières multiples et variées nous avons
énormément d'établissements qui
proposent multiples parcours
il faut que les étudiants les lycéens
tentes et le courage il soit encouragé à
tenter at entier à l'excellence a tenté
ce qu'ils ont envie sans aucun frein
sans aucune auto censure pour nous ce
serait déjà une bonne qu'à une bonne
chose que les étudiants entrant
confiance dans les filières même les
plus difficiles
nous nous sommes favorables à la
création d'un portail unique vous
parliez d'admission postbac de
l'orientation active
c'est une bonne chose il faut aller plus
loin il faut que les entretiens soient
systématisées il faut également quand on
s'inscrit à l'université qu'on
s'inscrive également qu'on remplit son
dossier social étudiant qui permet
d'accéder aux aides sociales du crous en
même temps faire un portail unique que
l'on remplit répendant sont à un
terminal pour remplir l'intégralité des
formalités ou simplement pour permettre
à l'étudiant de bénéficier de tous les
dispositifs qui existent et que son
orientation et sa situation future ne
soit pas le résultat d'un défaut
d'information
mais bel et bien un choix et c'est à
partir de ce choix qu'on peut construire
son avenir est envisagé un premier cycle
universitaire d'une manière plus sereine
on parle de l'orientation active
je préfère le terme d' orientation
progressive progressif parce que un
lycéen ne sait pas exactement s'il va
faire un doctorat de chimie organique ou
s'il préférait plutôt faire des études
de pharmacie ou des études d'ingénieur
dans tel ou tel domaine
pour nous il est nécessaire qu'ils aient
une augmentation progressive pendant la
licence à premier et une aile un
généraliste
se spécialiseraient au fur et à mesure
une approche progressive diversifié au
départ puis on se spécialiseraient au
fur et à mesure du cursus universitaire
vous avez rappelé que la loi libertés et
responsabilités des universités à
instaurer comme mission la séance
l'orientation et l'insertion
professionnelle oui dans son article
premier en effet mais ce n'est pas une
préoccupation nouvelle de notre
enseignement supérieur
les iut ont été créé en 1970 184 tournée
ajoute le professionnel à établissement
public à caractère culturel historique
et scientifique
en effet force est de constater que le
résultat est mitigé
certaines filières compte excellente en
d'excellentes autonation professionnels
nous sont plus fragiles
il faut poursuivre ses efforts ses
efforts passe par pour nous la mise en
place et le renforcement la montée en
puissance des bureaux d'aidé à
l'insertion professionnelle prévue par
la loi puisque pour nous le seul et
unique moyen de d'être efficacement
intégrés dans le marché du travail
c'est d'abord de le connaître du
savoir-faire les deux motivations de
remplir un cv mais également de
connaître le monde du travail à travers
les stages des stages encadrés
pédagogiquement intégrés dans les cursus
qui ont une valeur pédagogique également
une valeur de formation au monde
professionnel à au travail en équipe qui
ne s'acquiert pas forcément sur les
bancs de l'université
7 tous ces aspects qui doivent être
traitées au sein de bp et qu'il faut
qu'ils touchent tous les étudiants pour
construire leur projet professionnel
personnel tout au long de leur cursus
pour nous ce baip est à une des clés de
cette insertion professionnelle réussie
une autre un autre aspect est l'échec
l'échec en licence qu'ils catastrophique
qui peut être expliqué par de multiples
facteurs
certains disent un taux d'encadrement
trop faible d'autres disent une mauvaise
augmentation je pense qu'on ne peut pas
mettre en place enfin on ne peut pas
donner une seule raison c'est une
multiplicité de facteurs mais on ne
pense pas souvent ou au manque de
reconnaissance ou le manque de sentiment
d'appartenance qu'on les étudiants dans
leur établissement être fier de son
université avoir envie d'y aller du
travail et ça me fait également une
une raison et donc nous soutenons une
augmentation renforcer certes mais
également donner envie aux étudiants de
venir par l'établissement d'une
véritable vie de campus est une c'est un
point qu'il que nous avons souhaité
souligner ici formation professionnelle
tout au long des études mais également
tout au long de la vie il faut accepter
le fait qu'on puisse retourner à
l'université se former on peut la
quitter pour ça c'est sûr machines
travaillent plus pouvoir y revenir
mettre en place des décomptes des qui
nous permettrait de se doter d'une d'un
certain capital formation pour pouvoir y
retourner
puis ensuite acquérir des compétences
supplémentaires il serait inséré dans le
marché du travail
c'est une solution qui pourrait être
extrêmement intéressante
je terminerai en disant que nous vivons
à l'heure actuelle une crise économique
qui est grave qui nous fait prendre des
décisions pour y résoudre mais qui nous
offre également une opportunité qui est
de repenser de refonder une méthode un
système offrons-nous le droit de
chercher toutes les pistes de chercher
tout ce qui est fait en france à
l'étranger pour essayer de répondre
simplement à la demande des étudiants
qui est de se construire un avenir
merci merci à vous à vous messieurs
bonjour je suis baki youssoufou le
président de la confédération étudiante
alors tout d'abord j'ai
parler uniquement des étudiants par par
un corporatisme mais surtout par
efficacité par respect aux autres jeunes
qui ne sont pas autour de cette table
donc les propositions que nous allons
faire à la confédération étudiante sont
des propositions en direction des
étudiants à savoir qu'il est question
les problématiques les autres jeunes les
intéressent mais on se sent pas apte à
les représenter et d'abord tout d'abord
monsieur le rapporteur les quatre
questions que vous posez pour nous sont
regroupés dans une seule question qui
est celle de l'orientation et de
l'insertion professionnelle
comment aujourd'hui le constat commun
que nous avons partagés depuis 2006
c'est de dire que aujourd'hui les jeunes
qui sortent de l'université se retrouve
les plus en plus au chômage
dans les premières années à la sortie de
l'ordre niveau des bac + 5
or le bac + 5 elle au niveau des
diplômes les plus élevés en france
donc pour nous c'est très grave qui est
un pays comme la france ne puisse plus
donner envie aux gens d'aller jusqu'au
niveau le plus haut niveau de diplôme
pour s'insérer dans leur vie et comment
est ce constat nous l'avons partagé en
2006 et c'est pourquoi en 2006 nous nous
sommes battus pour que les candidats aux
élections présidentielles ces positions
clairement sur l'aventuré alité de m une
nouvelle mission à l'université celle de
l'insertion professionnelle qui en plus
de la recherche et de la formation
permettra aux universités dé prendre en
charge l'insertion des étudiants qu'ils
forment pendant la formation et de les
accompagner à mieux réussir leur
insertion professionnelle
ainsi nous avons mené une campagne un
référendum dans des universités de 5000
étudiants ayant participé les différents
candidats se sont engagés à ce que les
différentes les principaux candidats je
dirais ils se sont engagés à ce qu'il
soit élu il mettrait en place cette
nouvelle mission cette nouvelle mission
étant aujourd'hui dans dans les textes
nous sommes posé la question cette
rentrée mais qu'est ce qui a changé
vraiment dans la vie des étudiants nous
avons lancé une enquête et a les
résultats que nous avons aujourd'hui
nous montre que les étudiants restent
encore préoccupés à ce sont 16 %
principalement par leur avenir
professionnel
et cet avenir les étudiants s'en
préoccupe parce que l'on la construction
même de leur formation ils n'ont pas eu
les moyens suffisants les moyens
nécessaires pour pouvoir faire des beaux
choix des formations et les étudiants il
ne demande pas qu'on les assists ils
demandent par qu'on les protège
ils demandent qu'on leur donne des armes
nécessaires pour pouvoir eux mêmes se
battre dans un monde qui est difficile
et qu'il devient un rôle de plus en plus
avec la crise
c'est pourquoi pour nous la question de
la troisième mission
nous avons mené la campagne avant même
que ça soit dans la loi donc nous sommes
bien sûr content que ça soit aujourd'hui
dans la loi la mise en place des baip
concept de réseau par rapport à cette
mission va dans le bon sens mais les
résultats tardent encore à venir
parce que aujourd'hui les universités
comme disait un certain nombre de
camarades ne publie pas encore l'étau
des débouchés de leur filière et les
étudiants nous dise dans notre enquête à
116% qu'ils aimeraient bien savoir
qu'est-ce qui est devenu c'est qu'ils
sont passés par leur filière
ça c'est une question centrale dans les
chais les étudiants aujourd'hui il
aimerait bien savoir qu'est-ce qui est
devenu c'est qu'ils sont passés par leur
filière et cette question résout en même
temps la question aussi des emplois non
pourvus parce que nous nous attirons
justin votre attention sur le fait qu'
il faut éviter les solutions d'entonnoir
c'est à dire il ya aujourd'hui des
emplois notre prouvé en france il ya de
plus en plus de diplômés
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qui ont des
diplômes pour pouvoir ces emplois ça ça
serrait des solutions dangereuses pour
nous il faut juste faire en sorte que
chaque étudiant puisse faire des choix
nécessaires et qu'il soit éclairé sur le
monde professionnel à sacha exactement
ce qui existe dès le lycée pour qu'ils
puissent s'orienter tout au long de sa
vie pour qu'ils puissent savoir qu'est
ce qui existe ça c'est la première
question sur la question de
l'orientation et la question de la à
trois émissions l'université menace sur
les questions du des passerelles pour
nous pensons que la question de
l'orientation et y parler aux questions
des passerelles parce que les
l'orientation est considéré en france
comme un moment de transition
or pour nous l'orientation doit se faire
de manière perpétuelle pour permettre à
l'étudiant l'échangé des filières d
s'orienter dans 12 des nouvelles
filières des composés avec des nouvelles
matières et de faire en sorte qu'ils
obtiennent un diplôme dont les
compétences sont valides au marché du
travail et sur la question mais n'a plus
spécifiquement de l'emploi les étudiants
nous disent à 80 % qu'ils savent que
leur formation à l'université quelle que
soit la formation leur procure des
compétences énormes
en même temps ils disent l'université ne
les met pas en valeur et que eux mêmes
se sentent mal à l'aise dès vendre ses
compétences donc aujourd'hui nous
pensons que les universités devraient
mettre suffisamment de moyens pour faire
en sorte que chaque étudiant puisse
avoir un portefeuille de compétences qui
validerait les compétences acquises dans
sa formation
mais en même temps les compétences
acquises en dehors de sa formation
pendant qu'il est à l'université en
dehors de la formation il ya aujourd'hui
50% des étudiants qui travaillent qui
déclare travail pendant leurs études et
si on met les étudiants qui travaillent
l'été on va jusqu'à 115 % et les
étudiants et nous disent on sait qu'on
acquiert des compétences lorsqu'on
travaille en plus de nos études on
apprend à travailler en groupe on n'a
pas digéré notre temps on apprend même
souvent à gérer un agenda d'une
entreprise sauf que ces compétences ne
sont ni valorisé par l'université et
donc les étudiants ne peuvent pas les
valoriser une fois sortis du système
universitaire donc les étudiants
demandent à c'est qu'il existe un
portefeuille de compétences qui mettrait
dans un même dans un même document ou
dans un même panier les compétences
acquises en plus de connaissances des
formations les compétences acquises dans
la formation et les compétences acquises
en plus de la formation qui s'assoit
associatif que ce soit du point de vue
emplois étudiants qui s asseoir du point
de vue les stages pour finir la question
pour finir sur la question des stages
nous estimons que
les étudiants sont très vigilants sur la
question du stage il n'aimerait pas que
les stages qui peuvent apporter de
vraies compétences devient des
remplacements des job et que les
étudiants aimerait que les stages ne
dépassent pas le cadre universitaire
c'est à dire que les stages hors cursus
soit considéré comme un cdd et que
l'étudiant qui ne peut pas aller
travailler l'été parce qu'il a un stage
ils puissent être en comptera dans
l'entreprise où les en stage donc soit
on interdit les stages hors cursus soit
on les considère clairement comme
l'essai d'un cdd pour ne pas pénaliser
des étudiants parce que aujourd'hui
jusqu'à 80 % d'étudiants travaillent
l'été
donc voilà les quelques réponses que
nous voulons a apporté à à cette
première série des questions et en
attendant les autres merci beaucoup et
nous allons passer effectivement aux
deux autres points qui sont financés
ressources revenu de l'étudiant et
logement 5 minutes chacun et auparavant
monsieur le rapporteur volistes un peu
et question qu'on s'était posé trois
questions simples
il ya une récente réforme des bourses
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut encore
l'adapter lisier manqué les occasions de
propositions pour renforcer le tenir
financière les étudiants et troisième
question concerne le logement que son
proposition matière de logement pour
étudiant toute question donc on commence
par oui avant de répondre à vos
questions
je ne ferai pas mystère de des
propositions de l'unef en matière de
renforcement de l'autonomie financière
nous proposons la mise en place d'une
allocation d'autonomie pour les jeunes
en formation et en insertion qui soit
n'ont pas un revenu minimal d'inactivité
mais une aide à la construction d'un
projet de formation d'insertion qui
repose sur la remise à plat de
l'ensemble du dispositif actuel que ce
soit les aides au logement les aides
directes en matière dette sociale
étudiante et également les exonérations
fiscales que touchent les familles au
titre de leurs enfants étudiants ou en
formation et de toutes les allocations
familiales
il ya besoin de créer un dispositif
nouveau universel
donc c'est un droit ou nouveau ouvert à
l'ensemble de la jeunesse et
individualisé pour une part en fonction
de critères propres à chaque jeune
proposons que les jeunes effectuent une
déclaration fiscale indépendante à
partir de 18 ans sur la base desquels on
pourrait calculer leurs revenus
on pourrait d'ailleurs aussi mesurer les
transferts intra familiaux qui comme ça
a été repris et sont aujourd'hui la
principale source de financement de la
formation mais qui s'ils existent sont
par nature profondément inégaux et
injuste socialement
donc on est dans une situation actuelle
du point de vue du financement de la
formation qui est quand même la priorité
aujourd'hui parce que on nous répond
souvent vous parlez de politique
jeunesse et vous résumer ça une aide à
la formation supérieure ça concerne deux
tiers des jeunes et d'un point de vue
politique
nous pensons qu'aujourd'hui ça doit être
une priorité de renforcer l'accès des
jeunes notamment des non qualifiés à une
formation qualifiante
donc on ne pourra pas faire l'impasse
d'une réponse à la discute et
financières que rencontrent les jeunes
pour avoir les moyens se forme et qui
est là je rappelle quand même que les
raisons financières sont aujourd'hui la
première cause d'interruption d'études
donc on peut me traiter par le biais du
logement on peut trouver d'autres angles
d'attaqué mais cette question là il est
néanmoins indispensable
nous pensons aujourd'hui que évidemment
ce projet a un coût
mais qu'il relève d'un choix de société
sur lesquels il sera difficile de faire
l'impasse
nous pensons que nous pouvons procéder
par étapes en la matière est qu une
première étape pourrait être la remise
en cause et c'est une priorité pour nous
si on veut vraiment parler de
l'autonomie
deux des dispositifs fiscaux dont
bénéficient aujourd'hui les familles qui
trouvent leurs enfants étudiants on est
l'indication très paradoxal en france on
est entre deux assez exceptionnelle en
europe
je vous fais pas le tableau mais les
pays du nord évidemment font le pari de
cette autonomie renforcée a sorti bien
évidemment de contrepartie et de
garanties en terme de réussite dans les
études de recherche d'emploi etc
c'est évidemment un sujet sur lequel il
faudra discuter mais n'inversons pas les
choses discutons des contreparties une
fois qu'on a posé un principe est un
droit deuxième chose dans les pays
latins c'est encore également par le
biais de la famille en france 7,1 entre
eux deux donc aujourd'hui on qui rend le
système totalement illisible et surtout
totalement anti redistributifs et
injuste socialement et j'insiste sur
cette dimension là on ne peut pas
traiter la question de la jeunesse si on
ne ne s'attaque pas non plus aux
inégalités qui se reproduisent instants
de la vie et qu'on compte qu'on traîne
pendant toute sa vie pour le pour le
futur et nous sommes également partisan
de sortir d'une logique de financement
de la formation qui soit logique
individuelle qu'il est encore que ça
soit par le biais de dispositifs
remboursable de prêts dont on a vu
d'ailleurs les prêts mise en oeuvre et
mise en place à la rentrée dernière par
valérie pécresse ont été un échec total
je reviens pas sur les accords de fond
que nous avons avec eux le droit à
l'endettement que ça ouvert pour des
jeunes et ajouté endettement à une
insertion professionnelle difficile
après les études c'est quand même un
problème au delà des éléments de
principe et au delà du fait que les
banques ne sont pas prêts aujourd'hui à
ouvrir les vannes des crédits
individuels
ça pose est quand même une on a constaté
un échec parce que les étudiants ne
veulent pas prendre ce risque la
ministre avait parlé de 15 minutes près
au 30 décembre
soixante mille pour la fin de l'année
2009 il y en a à ce jour de 1300 qui ont
été décaissés donc voilà je pense que il
faut sortir un peu des préconçues
idéologique en la matière on a essayé
essayé
l'ensemble de ces formules pendant
longtemps ça n'a pas résolu le
le problème avant de répondre juste à
vos questions je termine je vais
rapidement sur ce sujet gars sur la
question de l'allocation autonomie
notre position est de dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut sortir les
étudiants dans des situations de
dépendance dans lesquelles ils sont et
jeunes dépendance familiale j'en ai dit
un mot également dépendance à la
précarité notamment des petits bouts
il s'agit pas de dire qu' il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui une masse importante
d'étudiants obligés de travailler côté
de ses études il s'agit de reconnaître
abandonné que la vocation sociale en
étudiant c'est d'étudier ces de se
former et qu'on pourra avoir l'ensemble
des on pourra voir lens ont des
exigences nécessaires en direction des
jeunes en matière de formation à partir
du moment où leur donner les moyens de
le faire dans de bonnes conditions et
qu'aujourd'hui salariat étudiant est une
une cause de renforcement de l'échec et
je fais juste la remarque suivante c'est
quand même paradoxal sait jamais dans
les grandes écoles jamais dans les facs
de médecine jamais dans les classes
préparatoires et là où les publics sont
socialement plutôt homogène qu'on a les
moyens de cumuler les emplois et des
études c'est toujours dans les filières
qui sont socialement celles qui
accueillent les jeunes les plus en
difficulté donc ça pose quand même une
question de justice sociale je crois
importante
il ya des effets en termes de progrès
social en termes d'effets
macroéconomiques à une telle mesure
on libère des emplois un nombre
important d'emplois et dans le contexte
actuel d'augmentation du chômage je
pense que c'est un élément important
on augmente le nombre de jeunes
qualifiés et de jeunes disposant d'une
qualification et ce sont les emplois de
demain préparer l'après crise année site
aussi dès maintenant de mettre le paquet
sur l'information ça en effet une telle
mesure en effet fortement redistributif
notamment depuis qu'il y a une grande
majorité des jeunes qui sont en
formation supérieure quand on était sur
104 50 milliards deux cent mille jeunes
faire un dispositif spécifique c'était
les enfants des milieux sociaux
favorisés
aujourd'hui on est dans un dispositif
largement redistributif on serait dans
un dispositif largement distributif je
termine juste je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de répondre aux rapporteurs et la
réforme des bourses son principal
problème c'est qu'elles étaient
insuffisantes
laurent wauquiez avait parlé en 2006 de
nécessité d'une politique pluriannuel à
hauteur de 350 millions qui permettent
d'augmenter le nombre de boursiers
notamment vers les classes moyennes et
le montant des aides
on a été sur à la rentrée 2007
une annonce
des annonces construit autour de 50
millions donc problème de l'ambition
deuxième problème la réforme des bourses
à modifier les critères d'attribution
on a beaucoup ramer pour faire en sorte
que notamment les objectifs fixés par la
ministre de 50 mille nouveaux boursière
cette rentrée soit atteint les plafonds
n'ont pas été assez relevé et beaucoup
d'étudiants se sont retrouvés avec une
aide moins importante parce
comprenez-moi ans contre l'éloignement
etc on a un peu rectifié les choses mais
pas suffisamment il faut rétablir sont
deux critères qui ont été supprimés
précédemment je ne développe pas et nous
pensons aujourd'hui
nonobstant la le dispostif global qu'il
faudra mettre en place et dont j'ai
parlé qui a besoin en priorité en
direction des étudiants d'un effort d'un
nouvel effort pluriannuel en matière
d'amélioration des conditions de vie
étudiante la mise en place d'un dixième
mois de bourse pour couvrir le coût de
la rentrée
le prix de la république a fait des
gestes en matière de dead notamment en
matière d'allocation de rentrée scolaire
pour un ensemble de familles et
d'enfants et d'étudiants c'est le seul
ou la seule population aujourd'hui on
n'a rien fait pour justement couvrir le
coût de la rentrée donc dans le contexte
ça aurait un sens et appartements ou
l'année universitaire s'est allongée
depuis 2003-2004 75% et tuant rentrer
avant le 15 septembre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on touche peu bourse
qu'à partir du mois d'octobre cette
mesure là est importante et après
évidemment des mesures d'augmentation du
système sur lesquelles je ne reviens pas
vous avez parlé déjà beaucoup je vais
très court je répond directement à vos
questions concernant la réforme des
bourses effectivement l a été
c'était un bon progrès cette année en
termes d'augmentation du nombre de
boursiers échelon zéro et même création
des fonds 6
après il faudrait que de plus en plus
que 7,7 sociale soit adaptée aux besoins
des étudiants à différents niveaux dans
un premier temps il faudrait que le coût
soit un guichet unique des bourses et à
dire que vous avez différentes système
d'aidé sociale qui existe pour les
étudiants qui sont rattachés au mr la
culture les ips y soit un smic sont
rattachés aux régions donc parler de
manque de lisibilité ce niveau là une
chose importante c'est déjà de faire que
le crous soit l'interlocuteur unique
pour tous les demandeurs de bourse
ensuite il faut effectivement que c'est
dès ce soir et les aides sociales pardon
soit adaptée aux besoins réels de
l'étudiant donc j'ai déjà parlé des
effets de seuil tout à l'heure
qui existe et donc il faudrait mettre en
place une sorte de linéarisation des
bourses de telle sorte qu'en fonction
des revenus on puisse avoir une
augmentation une courbe qui est
augmentée tu ne sois pas de par effet de
pallier la deuxième chose et la question
d'une répartition plus équitable des
aides
on parle souvent de la demi part fiscale
donc nous on est plutôt pour et
fortement pour la suppression de cette
demi part fiscale et une redistribution
un petit peu plus équitable des aides
aux étudiants et qu'ils soient
réinvestis à ce niveau là dans un
système de bourses au delà de ça on
prend encore trop en compte le revenu
des parents dans le calcul des bourses
il faut aussi un certain moment se
rendre compte qu'une indépendance avérée
de certains étudiants et qu'elle doit
être prise en compte
au delà de ça il ya aussi la
particularité en termes d'années
universitaire d'étudiants effectivement
comme comme jean baptiste prévost le
disais il ya la rentrée étudiante qui
est un moment important on savait de
nombreuses années où la fage milite pour
une allocation de rentrée étudiante de
telle sorte que les étudiants puissent
s'installer et puissent faire part à
leur premier dépenses importantes de
telle sorte qu'ils puissent subvenir à
leurs besoins dès le début de l'année le
10e mois de bourse c'est aussi par de
m'appeler réforme lmd
effectivement nous sommes à 10 -
effectif avec les examens et c'est
quelque chose d'important apprendre à
prendre en compte
au-delà de ça sur le logement étudiant
je vais être un petit peu plus rapide il
ya des préconisations qui ont déjà été
faites par le député anciaux on est en
retard sur pas mal de sur pas mal de
programmes et on est loin d'atteindre
les objectifs
là encore il faut un investissement
supplémentaire pour rattraper ce retard
génère c'est à lui que nous ce matin et
on nous expliquait qu avant 2020 on
n'aurait pas rempli les objectifs d'ores
et déjà il faut savoir qu'il faudra
attendre 2 cpr pour pouvoir réussir à
à répondre aux besoins actuels de
rénovation et construction du logement
étudiant
ça c'est une chose fondamentale il faut
penser si le jean et finances dans une
perspective plus rien eu elle pas
uniquement voir maintenant les objectifs
la d'urgence etc
mais vraiment construire sur les dix
vingt trente prochaines années en
fonction de l'évolution possible du
nombre d'étudiants de leur répartition
géographique le les prés salés les 10
pôles de compétitivité de qui ont été
mis en place par le plan campus ont
aussi des choses à prendre en compte qui
vont pas mal modifié le paysage
universitaire et tout ça est à penser
dès maintenant de telle sorte d'offrir
une offre convenable pour les peaux les
étudiants au delà de ça il faut aussi
permettre d'accéder à l'immobilier privé
aux étudiants j'ai encore énormément
d'étudiants notamment issus des classes
moyennes qui ne peuvent pas accéder aux
logements crous et qui doivent pouvoir
par différentes mécanisme accéder assez
facilement à du logement privé
ça peut être conventionnée avec avec le
crous et de telles sortes de dispositifs
qui existent déjà qui seront logement en
ville je ne vais pas développer ça aussi
ça va être mis en place
concernant le l'autonomie financière des
jeunes alors je suis un petit peu plus
réservé que l'unef
effectivement il faut qu'il y ait une
aide aux étudiants de telle sorte qu'ils
puissent tenir convenablement leurs
études mais nous ne sommes pas pour une
sorte de salaire étudiant qui a été
capté de proposer encore une fois ça
doit être
ouais j'ai passé les étudiants mais vous
l'utilisez temps en temps une sorte de
location d'autonomie la jeunesse
effectivement il faut des leviers qui
permettent aux étudiants de notamment
ceux issus des classes moyennes qui sont
souvent les plus pénalisées dans la
mesure où ils n'accèdent pas aux bourses
et ils ont beaucoup de difficultés c'est
sûr qui salarient plus il faut avoir un
système qui les aident à à mener à bien
leur étude
alors je n'ai pas de solution miracle à
mon avis c'est encore quelque chose qui
est écrit au cas par cas étudiants par
étudiant et donc il faut plus une aide
personnalisée à mon avis et en
accompagnement personnalisé en notamment
avec le projet professionnel de
l'étudiant qui doit être pris en compte
pour lui à lui verser une sorte
d'autonomie financière qui va lui
permettre de réussir voilà j'espère que
j'ai pas trop dépasser
bonjour jean paul vialle dégage in arms
2 min alors pour être répondre à vos
questions directement l'autonomie
financière pour lui ni comme on vous l'a
dit l'autonomie c'est un processus et ça
ne se décrète pas même avec la carotte
d'une autonomie d'une nouvelle
allocation d'autonomie
c'est quelque chose l'autonomie
financière l'allocation d'autonomie qui
a un vieux cheval de bataille de l'unef
notamment et toulouse de tous les partis
de gauche
c'est un vieux cheval dont on sait
malheureusement que contrairement à ce
qui est dit est dit c'est pas plus juste
socialement il faut m'expliquer comment
quand dès lors qu'on donne la même aide
à tout le monde on aura on aura plus de
justice sociale que le système actuel
qui est un système sur critères sociaux
et qui permet de donner de l'aide à ceux
qui en ont réellement besoin
donc on a véritablement quelque chose
qui qui doit être pensée très
différemment
l'autonomie financière elles se basent
d'abord sur un revenu qu un revenu
stable un revenu qui est souvent qui
doit être un revenu qui vient de
l'emploi donc il ya plusieurs choses qui
peuvent être mises en place
alors effectivement le pour les
étudiants les jobs étudiants
contrairement là aussi aux chiffres ont
été donnés ci on cite des chiffres
sérieux l'insee parle de 13 %
d'étudiants salariés et pas de 50 % et 3
%
on est du coup le pays européen où on a
le moins d'étudiants qui travaillent
pendant leurs études
et si on veut améliorer ça puisque
effectivement comme l'a dit quelqu'un
d'autre
le travail pendant les études permet
d'améliorer l'aspect professionnel du
murs de beaucoup de cursus est un
véritable plus au moment de l'insertion
professionnelle si on veut améliorer ça
il faut un meilleur accompagnement
pédagogique de ces étudiants là une
meilleure valorisation de leur
expérience et aussi peut-être des
mesures qui permettent de défiscaliser
encore plus fortement le travail des
étudiants que ce qui a déjà été fait
dans la loi tepa
donc c'est une première chose qui peut
être mise en place
la seconde chose c'est effectivement le
système de bourse le système de bourse
celle qu'il a été mise en place et elle
qui a été réformé va dans le bon sens et
permet justement d'aider déjà beaucoup
d'étudiants et les études de lever homme
montre bien d'ailleurs que les étudiants
en gros qui bénéficient des bourses sont
ceux qui ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat
relatif le plus augmenté et le moins
diminué sur la gueule sur la période des
dix dernières années
aujourd'hui le vrai problème le vrai
problème que rencontrent les questions
sont les étudiants des classes moyennes
et comment on aide les étudiants de
classes moyennes effectivement ça la
réforme du système de bourse
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas du tout
répondu alors si on veut encore
améliorer le système de bourse actuel il
est quand même quelque chose notamment
permis de créer ce qui fait falloir
répondre rapidement aux qu'elle va
répondre tellement c'est que aujourd'hui
le revenu le montant des bourses est
calculé sur le revenu des parents de
l'année n - 1
en période de crise quand on a des
parents qui sont commerçants quand on a
des parents qui sont salariés qui
perdent leur emploi
ça veut dire qu'il faut attendre un an
et demi avant de pouvoir bénéficier
d'une bourse s'il ya un accident dans la
famille et donc il faut qu'on soit
beaucoup plus réactif on ne peut pas
laisser des étudiants soumis simplement
au régime dette d'urgence il faut qu'on
puisse rapidement faire bénéficier pour
un étudiant dont les parents viennent de
perdre leur emploi ou pour un étudiant
dont les parents sont commerçants et
voyaient leur revenu d'activité baisser
rapidement qu'on puisse tout de suite
intégré dans le système de bourses est
pas tant un an et demi avant de taxer
les sites de bourg ça serait vraiment
quelque chose qui permettrait de
répondre rapidement pour les classes
moyennes
il ya une seule chose aujourd'hui qui
est envisageable c'est la solution qui
est mise en place dans tous les autres
pays du monde
c'est une allocation remboursables un
prêt étudiant qui soient garanties par
l'état
effectivement le système qu'on a mis en
place aujourd'hui en france était un peu
un satisfaisant parce que c'était avec
des prêts bancaires il y avait peu de
banques qui avaient joué le jeu ce qui
existe et ce qu'avait été d'ailleurs une
des propositions
sarkozy pendant la campagne
présidentielle qu'on avait soutenu
fortement
c'était la création d'un prêt à taux
zéro garanties par l'état avec ce qui
est le plus important dans ce système de
prêt un système de remboursement qui
soit spécifiquement étudiée pour les
jeunes et c'est à dire si on veut
permettre à des jeunes de recourir aux
prêts bancaires ou auprès tout
simplement il faut qu'on leur garantisse
que ça sera pas un fardeau et qu'ils
auront toutes les facilités pour le
rembourser ce qui existe dans les autres
pays du monde
c'est un une garantie qu'on rembourse
ont presque de leurs qu'on a un contrat
à durée déterminée ou on pro à table
sont revenus ce qui fait qu'on n'a
jamais un fardeau d'entrée et donc c'est
ce système là vers lequel il faut aller
c'est le seul système qui permet un
effet de levier important et qui permet
de passer d'un système aujourd'hui ou 15
% des jeunes sont aidés en france un
système comme il en existe en nouvelle
zélande ou 100 % des jeunes sont aidés
grâce un système d'allocation
remboursables donc on a vraiment un
quelque chose qui pour nous est très
important c'est ce système de prêt le
renforcement effectivement des revenus
du travail est de même pour les
étudiants donc des jobs étudiants avec
une meilleure défiscalisation pour la
question du logement pour faire pour
pardon défiscalisation de de l'emploi
étudiant parce qu'aujourd'hui en gros
l'emploi étudiant ça fonctionne la loi
tepa permet des étudiants qui
travaillent pendant l'été de voir leurs
revenus défiscalisées dès lors qu'ils
travaillent pendant l'année ils sont
fiscalisées puisque ça ne correspond à
peu près à trois mois maximum
de travail pendant l'été pour le
logement là aussi contrairement à ce que
ce qui a été dit précédemment
effectivement si on suit les préceptes
du plan anciaux il faudra 10 ans 15 ans
pour permettre à 10% des étudiants de
trouver un logement
si on continue la logique du logement
tout crous il faudra dix ans pour que
les étudiants se contentent dans une
chambre de 9 m² il ya un moment donné où
il va falloir peut-être pas lancé à
autre chose et regarder ce qui se fait
ailleurs notamment il ya un des nouveaux
acteurs qui sont qui est aujourd'hui ont
une importance plus important dans le
milieu de l'enseignement supérieur c'est
les universités elles ont la maîtrise de
leurs de leur foncier
elles ont la capacité à contracter des
partenariats public-privé et ça ça peut
créer un véritable levier pour créer du
logement étudiant et d'ailleurs
certaines universités elles sont encore
plus nombreuses pour l'instant n'y en a
qu'une seule ont décidé de s'investir
sur cette question là ce qui permet
véritablement de lever et de créer
beaucoup plus de logements
la deuxième chose qui peut être aussi
intéressant c'est de faciliter le fait
que les collectivités locales
investissent dans le logement et
logement qu'il y en ait une des
propositions que lui nié les faits c'est
une modification de la loi sru pour
permettre que le logement étudiant soit
totalement intégrée dans les 20% de
logements sociaux ce qui permettrait à
beaucoup de municipalités de créer du
logement étudiant de façon un peu plus
important sa c2 deux mesures qui peuvent
être prises rapidement et la troisième
mesure c'est effectivement une aura un
renforcement de toutes les dispositifs
qui permettent de rassurer les
propriétaires privés en lait en
défiscalisant certaines choses mais là
la seule vis à vis des spécificités des
jeunes et du logement
une des premières spécificités des
jeunes élus logement c'était jeunes sont
beaucoup plus mobile que les autres que
les autres catégories de la population
et donc ils ont tendance à changer plus
souvent de logements donc un
propriétaire préfère louer à quelqu'un
un couple installé plutôt qu'un jeune il
faut qu'on soit capable et notamment la
les universités les étés les grands
établissements peuvent mettre en place
des structures qui sont capables de dire
aux propriétaires on vous assure
et on vous garantit la rotation des
étudiants de façon à ce que votre
l'ajout de logements ne soit jamais
vacances c'est ce qui a été fait par
certaines écoles notamment dans la
région d'angers et c'est ce qui permet à
beaucoup d'étudiants de bénéficier
beaucoup plus simplement de l'accès au
parc privé parce qu'autrement si les
clients et tout seul face à
1 au parc privé il a des difficultés qui
sont quasiment infranchissable donc il
faut effectivement un intermédiaire est
interdite aux médias c'est bien souvent
le seul possible c'est l'établissement
d'enseignement supérieur et donc là il
ya des mesures à prendre de façon à
faciliter notamment la colocation avec
une garantie de l'établissement face
faciliter la rotation dans le logement
avec une garantie de l'établissement de
façon à ce que vraiment on ouvre toutes
les modalités pour le logement parce que
c'est la première des difficultés des
jeunes aujourd'hui
et là dessus les étudiants ont des
difficultés mais finalement ce sont
plutôt les mieux servis puisque on aura
peut-être le temps d'en parler dans les
questions les jeunes apprentis sont
heureux ceux qui étudient dans les cfa
sont dans des situations qui sont encore
plus difficiles et qu'il a par contre
n'ont aucun système qui leur permet de
répondre alors nécessité de se loger
merci beaucoup donc j'allais je vais
passer sur je réponde à vos trois points
concernant la récente réforme des
bourses de la ministre la ministre a
enclenché l'année dernière c'est une ça
permet de rendre le système plus lisible
plus visible c'est une bonne chose mais
il est inachevée inachevé parce que la
simplification des nombres de critères a
fait que les étudiants en situation de
handicap les y tu as les étudiants ayant
des enfants ont été exclues de ce
dispositif et nous avons demandé à la
ministre un état des lieux des
dispositifs qui se sont mis en place
pour résoudre à ces demandes bien
spécifiques
le dispositif des bourses sur critères
sociaux répondant quant à lui a dit
à une disette fait que tous les
étudiants partagent que sont la distance
par rapport au foyer des parents le
nombre de frères et soeurs dans
l'enseignement supérieur etc et le
revenu des parents nous avons des
mesures dit des recommandations pour
l'améliorer la linéarisation de ce
dispositif car à l'heure actuelle les
effets de seuil qui permettent
l'attribution des bourses ont sont
catastrophiques pour un euro de plus
gagné par le foyer fiscal pendant un an
il ya une différence de 1400 euros par
an pour les étudiants ce qui est très
important
l'année universitaire s'allonge nous
demandons un versement sur 10 mois des
bourses avec un effort tout particulier
sur la rentrée
entrée qui le moment de l'année où les
coûts sont les plus importants nous
demandons également la mise en place de
que les crous wade guichet unique pour
l'ensemble des aides à destination des
étudiants parce qu'il existe de
multiples oz 150-200 aide que ce soit
des collectivités régionales découle à
des queues de la région des départements
des villes des fondations d etc il ya
énormément directive dead
nous demandons que les financements le
financement des études ne soient pas une
question d'information ou de manque
d'information des étudiants mais bel et
bien que le toutes ces aides sont
répertoriés au tournant guichet unique
qui devrait être piloté par le crous le
versement des bourses pourraient
également être améliorés je ne rentrerai
pas dans le détail par rapport à un
rapport de l'igaenr de 2006 qui est
extrêmement intéressant et qui propose
que les crous soit ordinateurs du
paiement des bourses qui permettrait de
râles de à raccourcir fortement les
délais de paiement on parle d'autonomie
financière les bourses permettent de
répondre à des besoins spécifiques des
étudiants défavorisés
mais il ne faut pas oublier les
étudiants des classes moyennes
souvent trop riches pour avoir les
bourses est trop pauvre pour avoir les
aides fiscales
ces classes moyennes ne sont pas aidés
nous proposons de relever les plafonds
des bourses sur critères sociaux et
également d'avoir une approche plus sur
le long terme qui serait sur une
dotation en capital de ces étudiants
enclenché pendant leur enfance
alimenté par la puissance publique et
également par les familles qui dispose
néanmoins d'une certaine capacité
d'épargné et qui permettent
de doter les étudiants à l'entrée de
danse on ne lance dans l'enseignement
supérieur d'un capital certains qui lui
permettrait d'aborder ses études avec un
petit peu plus de sécurité
un rapide calcul une initiation et en a
250 euros puis à un abondement à la
discrétion des familles mais de 30 euros
par mois d'autres l étudiant de 10000
euros de capital à l'entrée dans
l'enseignement supérieur ce qui peut
être assez intéressant pour lui même
concernant les prêts nous considérons
que les prêts doivent être un recours
marginal pourquoi marginale parce que
nous souhaitons que étudiés ne signifie
pas s'endetter
néanmoins les étudiants ont des fois
besoin de prêts il faut le reconnaître
c'est une réalité
le dispositif des prêts pécresse n'est
pas satisfaisant puisqu'il ne met pas en
place un remboursement qui est en
fonction du salaire qui demande à seuil
de déclenchement nous demandons à ce
qu'on mette en place un seuil de
déclenchement également une interruption
de ce remboursement en cas de périodes
difficiles de chômage etc
donc nous demandons des garanties
supplémentaires pour le dispositif des
prêts les prêts étudiants
concernant le logement il faut renforcer
l'offre de logements l'offre de
logements crous cent cinquante mille
chambres 2 millions 300 mille étudiants
il en manque il en manque beaucoup le
rapport anciaux de a préconisé cette
nuit réhabilitation 5000 constructions
par an les objectifs ne sont pas
atteints ont été atteints pour la
première fois et de justesse grâce au
plan de relance
il faut poursuivre un effort majeur de
la nation en matière de logements
étudiants crous et je dirais même plus
dans la région ile-de-france où la
situation est extrêmement tendue mais le
logement crous ne répondra pas à toutes
les demandes
il faut également l'admettre il faut
permettre aux étudiants d'aller se loger
dans d'autres structures qu'elles soient
publiques ou privées
néanmoins un frein un frein important
le logement est la principale dépense
des jeunes les étudiants il faut que les
aspects de caution et de garant soit
rendu beaucoup plus facile pour les
étudiants élargir le dispositif de loca
pass porter le la puissance publique au
service de cette caution de ce garant
pour faire
ce ne soit pas un parcours du combattant
de se loger et de selongey d'une manière
assez convenable
c'est pourquoi nous demandons à ce que
les logements et qui sont à vocation des
étudiants et soit labellisée par le
crous qui est l'expert depuis cinquante
50 ans dans le logement étudiant
il est le seul à même avoir dit
véritables critères qu'on appelle le
référentiel crous et que cela
permettrait également un meilleur
dialogue entre les étudiants et leur
bailleur donc nous sommes en faveur de
ces deux c'est différent de ces
différents points
oui merci
la question du financement des études de
l'accès à l'autonomie et du logement
pour nous s associe à la question du
choix
c'est à dire que l'on l'autonomie c'est
un choix ce n'est pas à ces derniers une
attribution c'est devenu un combat c'est
unis quelque chose qu'on te laisserais
acquérir tout seul mais ces types de
données suffisamment d'armes pour
pouvoir faire des choix et dans ton
avenir alors cette question d'autonomie
du parcours d'autonomie pour nous elle
est elle au centre du débat du
financement des études et aussi du
logement étudiant
pourquoi aujourd'hui nous sommes tous
d'accord que en plus la crise vient le
renforcer que les bourses aux critères
sociaux ne sont plus suffisants et
surtout qu'à en loge dans ce camp on est
étudiant dans certaines grandes villes
ce n'est plus suffisant
néanmoins les étudiants ils plébiscitent
un système basé sur les critères sociaux
et donc la bourse va être la base pour
les étudiants et notre enquête démontre
une fois de plus à 90% les étudiants
disent qui est la base des l'aide
sociale doit être les bourses aux
critères sociaux parce que ça permet de
donner plus à ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin
ensuite les étudiants disent ces
systèmes étant insuffisants aujourd'hui
à beaucoup d'étudiants qui travaillent
on peut on peut
discuter sur les chiffres en 2007 le
conseil économique et social a rendu un
rapport sur la situation des étudiants
qui démontre qu'il ya 40 % d'étudiants
qui travaillent et cette année l'année
la même année l'observatoire de la vie
étudiante démontrent les mêmes chiffres
donc on peut plus dire aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a pas suffisamment l'étudiant en
france qui travaille
sauf si on veut l'ignorer ou on veut
c'est mettre la main sur le visage et
notamment les étudiants disent
aujourd'hui et le rapport dit c'est
est-ce le démontrent les étudiants qui
travaillent au délà des 15 heures
risquent d'échouer dans leurs études
alors nous c'est que nous proposons et
c'est ce que nous allons proposer à
haut-commissaire haut commissaire à la
jeunesse que la puissance publique
complète le revenu des salariés
étudiants à hauteur de 15 heures ça veut
dire quoi
avec un étudiant qui n'est pas éligibles
quels que soient les critères fixés à la
bourse qui a un peu de temps pour aller
travailler au lieu que ce travail là
devient pénalisant pour un coureur pour
ses études que la puissance publique
complète sont revenus à la limite d'un
certain seuil
horaires et ensuite et ça c'est une base
des compères pour compléter le système
des bourses une autre une autre solution
pour compléter les bourses
donc pour nous un système social est
basé toujours sur la bourse qui doit
augmenter en nombre et en volume mais
complété par le premier pilier qui est
celui des durées venue du salariat
étudiant
ensuite il ya les bourses d'entreprise
pourquoi les bourses d'entreprises parce
que aujourd'hui beaucoup de filières
sont des pépinières pour beaucoup
d'entreprises et il faudrait donc
associer les entreprises pour qui il
participe au financement avec et l'état
comme garant des de ce système
ça voudrait dire quoi un étudiant qui
rentre dans un bts des porcelaines en
limousin qui veut travailler dans une
entreprise spécialisée qui chargent
d'orientation l'état se substitue pour
que le peu de l'argent investi par
l'entreprise devient un prêt entre
l'état et l'étudiant qu'il remboursera
une fois
et dans sa vie laquelle les entreprises
puissent participer est progressivement
au financement des études de certaines
filières et un troisième pilier c'est
donc une allocation universelle
remboursables qui seraient avancés par
l'état par les banques parce
qu'aujourd'hui ajoute avec la crise les
étudiants c'est méfie beaucoup des
systèmes bancaires et à juste titre
parce que tous les jours on en découvre
un petit peu plus donc les étudiants nés
à mort sont prêts à à apprendre une
allocation auprès d'elles étant
remboursables et remboursables une fois
insérée dans un travail durable et
remboursables on pourra trouver les
solutions soient indexés aux salaires
soient remboursés intégralement par
l'étudiant lui même est ce un tel
système est efficace parce que elle
permettra en elle est universelle elle
permettra à tout étudiant d'y accéder en
plus des des autres formes dead et elle
est efficace parce qu'elle permettra
d'en a pâti d'une génération t d que la
solidarité en influence les caisses d'un
tel système
voilà donc les trois piliers d'élèves
social pour ce qui concerne le logement
pour nous nous pensons que que ce soit
les rapports oui j'ai finir sur le
logement le losc et les différents
rapports avec eux a été rendu public et
les projets de la ministre de construire
de nouveaux logements étudiants
c'est saidal ça va dans le bon sens bien
sûr vu la situation
mais ce n'est pas suffisant il faut
répondre aux préoccupations immédiates
des étudiants est aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'étudiants sont dans des situations
hyper précaire en matière de logement et
pour cela il suffit pas de construire un
nouveau logement il suffit pas d'échangé
d'acteur il suffit surtout qu'est tous
les acteurs se mettent autour de la
table qu'on propose des solutions
immédiates transitoire qui permet à
chaque étudiant les pouvoir se loger et
au moins que les acteurs publics et les
territoires créé des espaces où l'offre
et la demande de logements peuvent se
rencontrer dans un territoire bien donné
merci beaucoup et bonne route à chacun
de vous
c'était la table ronde organisée par la
mission commune d'information du sénat
sur la politique en faveur des jeunes
table ronde avec les syndicats étudiants
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur public sénat